algunos lo esperaban Ángela recordemos
que él tenía anunciado una visita para
mañana martes a Polonia y algunos van
los pensamientos pensaba que el
presidente Joe Valdez podría visitar
sorpresivamente
Pero recordemos y lo que han dicho desde
Estados Unidos es que él tenía un evento
agendado para esta noche y salió en
secreto desde Washington nadie lo sabía
Así que cuando esta mañana empezaron a
verse que las calles de quién estaban
totalmente cerradas el tráfico no podía
transitar por lo que es la capital de
una ciudad que es bastante congestionada
empezaron las dudas y los rumores sobre
quién sobre si el presidente biden había
llegado a la ciudad tal como recordemos
que este es el inicio de esta semana en
las cuales se recuerda esa invasión a
gran escala comenzada por orden del
presidente Vladimir Putin el 24 de
febrero del año pasado es una semana muy
dolorosa para los ucra pero también con
un gran significado porque la primera
intención que tenía el presidente ruso
era tomar la capital de Ucrania quien
recordemos esa gran columna de tanques
que viajaban hacia tomar a la ciudad que
fue atacada y toda la ciudad todos los
suburbios de la ciudad están bastante
destruidos lo que demuestra que era la
obsesión el presidente Putin Así que ver
hoy al presidente byden caminando con el
presidente por las partes más
importantes de la ciudad es una gran
Victoria para los ucranianos con
sacrificado muchísimo Durante este año
Catalina baiden anunció un nuevo paquete
de ayuda militar para que F de 500
millones de dólares que incluyen
municiones para los misiles
Qué impacto tendrá esto en el campo de
batalla
primero esto es una gran victoria de
Ucrania y también de vaiden contra
aquellos que dicen aquel sector
norteamericano que decía que no se podía
seguir con Carta blanca dando orden
armas a los ucranianos sin embargo en
las últimas semanas Has visto cómo se ha
intensificado esa campaña de las
autoridades ucranianas Empezando por el
presidente y no solamente pidiendo
tanques sino también aviones y
especialmente munición que es importante
y esencial en este momento en el frente
de batalla especialmente en esa Región
del donbas donde las ofensiva rusa y los
ataques sean intensificado en las
últimas semanas especialmente en esa
población que ha sido el centro de Las
batallas durante meses en donde la
situación de los ucranianos cada vez es
más difícil Así que esto es una gran
Victoria los ucranianos siguen
insistiendo que no pueden ser solamente
palabras y promesas sino que tiene que
llegar bastante rápido
porque les permiten no solamente
disparar a mayor Rango de distancia sino
también cortar las líneas de provisión y
abastecimiento de los rusos que son
bastante importantes para evitar que
sigan abasteciendo esas líneas del
frente especialmente la región del Don
vas pero también en la región de
saporilla al sur que va hacia la isla
hacia la isla de crimea hoy en poder y
en invasión de los rusos bien y
finalmente Catalina lo que todo el mundo
se pregunta cómo reaccionarán los rusos
ante la visita de biden
Pues si esa será la gran pregunta en el
momento en el que vaiden o se conocía
que vaiden estaban que sonaron las
alarmas en todo el país estaba todo el
país en rojo y la gran pregunta que se
hacen no solamente por la visita de Joe
biden sino durante esta semana es cómo
va a actuar el presidente va a seguir
atacando el país van a ver ataques
masivos como va a recordar este año de
Invasión a gran escala que realmente
según los ucranianos y lo que se ve en
el campo de batalla ha sido un fracaso
para Rusia a pesar de que ellos dictan
que ha sido lo contrario y que van
cumpliendo los objetivos de eso Que
ellos llamaron algún día una operación
especial pero que es una guerra invasión
a gran escala